c'est le rendez vous des formules 18 ces
catamarans de sport qui allie puissance
et finesse
parmi les équipages des champions du
monde d'europe des habitués des tours de
france et des amateurs éclairés et au
détour d'un fauteur eric livio et nathan
élèves de maintenance nautique odyssée
du marin il répare depuis deux mois un
vieux kata et pour la première fois vont
le tester et se tester en navigation sur
ce type de raid
c'est une passion je n'étais bateau et
ça mais on aime ça
honnêtement d'ailleurs déjà le f18 se
dilate whaou
alors que laguiole c'est parti pour la
première des cinq manches avec un
parcours cette année exclusivement en
côte caraïbe pour cause de sargasses
après un départ de schelcher les
concurrents doivent aller virer une
bouée à fort-de-france l'occasion de
repérer l'état de forme des équipages
notamment locaux le duo gillet poids
enroulé la première marque de parcours
en deuxième position mais la remontée
vers saint pierre des passages au près
et les des ventes dû à l'appeler vont
bouleverser le classement et comme prévu
les favoris se détachent du lot les
vainqueurs 2018 charles gâtés et orion
martin avec une option plus au large
évitez d'être encalminé à saint-pierre
et garderont la tête de course quasiment
jusqu'à l'arrivée
c'est vraiment une coordination dévoile
plus le barreur c'est vraiment un tout
on est deux sur le bateau donc il faut
vraiment que la voile soit bien réglée à
l'angle de la barre à un instant précis
et c'est là où on gratte les petits
centimètres dans pas de vent pour
pouvoir prendre en premier le vent de
l'autre côté de la montagne
mais attention le binôme boulogne veille
au grain emmanuel le barreur compte déjà
trois éditions victorieuse la 4e l'an
dernier lui a échappé en fin de raids
pour 16 minutes d'écart qui a donc de la
revanche dans l'air
les zones de vent et si vous
particulièrement dans les caraïbes sont
un peu changé il faut vraiment être
prendre des options de façon très
vivante très très direct ça peut être
sait jamais là visiblement c'est jamais
pareil de minarets sur l'autre donc il
faut être très attentif aux bateaux qui
sont autour de nous et puis c'est ce qui
se passe sur l'eau grosse déception en
revanche pour les leaders martinique et
l'an dernier leur quatrième place au
classement général les placés en
outsider cette année mais malgré un bon
début de parcours il termine cette
première manche avec trois quarts
d'heure de retard sur les vainqueurs on
s'est fait bloquer au carbet bêtement
s'est passé à droite à gauche
pas grand chose à faire et puis en
arrivant sur la perle
on a détalé aussi on est passé à travers
on a toute la journée catastrophe
quant à nos jeunes lycéens ils ont fait
le choix d'écourter le parcours histoire
de rester au contact de la flotte non
classé ils ont une tout autre objectif
enchaîné les cinq manches
en guise d'apprentissage et terminé la
semaine avec une belle formation en
poche